el presidente francés y el príncipe de
abu dhabi se miraron y aplaudieron
después de que el ministro de defensa de
emiratos árabes unidos- firmará un
acuerdo armamentístico sin precedentes
con parís el mayor pedido internacional
jamás realizado de aviones de guerra
franceses raphael 14.000 millones de
euros por 80 aeronaves de combate
emiratos también comprará 12
helicópteros militares caracas según
macrón se trata de contratos clave para
mantener la estabilidad en el golfo y de
la creación de puestos de trabajo en
francia
no podemos contraatacar el terrorismo si
no dialogamos con todos los actores y si
no tenemos relaciones estratégicas y
basadas en la confianza con los socios
que comparten nuestra agenda estos
contratos que firmamos son importantes
para nuestra economía crean empleos en
francia
emiratos árabes unidos- fue el quinto
mayor cliente de la industria bélica
francesa de 2011 a 2020 y con el
contrato de rafael sigue los pasos de su
rival del golfo qatar que junto con
egipto también hicieron sus compras
militares mientras parís defiende que
los contratos armamentísticos benefician
la estabilidad en medio oriente los
críticos señalan que eliseo está
ignorando las vulneraciones de derechos
humanos que protagonizan sus clientes
concretamente que las armas vendidas a
emiratos en el pasado han sido usadas en
la guerra de yemen francia promueve
estas ventas a pesar de que los emiratos
juegan un papel prominente en las
atrocidades militares perpetradas por su
coalición con arabia saudita en yemen
las ventas de armas francesas las
ambiguas alianzas militares en nombre
del antiterrorismo y el coste en
términos de vidas humanas será una
mancha imborrable del historial
diplomático de macrón en diciembre de
2020 cuando el presidente egipto abdel
fattah al sisi visitó parís emanuel
macrón defendió la venta de armamento al
cairo argumentando que las diferencias
sobre derechos humanos no deben
condicionar la cooperación estratégica